so you're on probation and you're doing
these you're almost getting caught
you're almost getting caught and you're
doing these really large scale
scams how does it get to the point where
you're on the run so I'm doing multiple
scams right so it's not just that I'm
doing the scams with the uh the
Reservoir Dog scams right I'm not just
doing those guys I'm also
creating other identities
because I've got other people that are
involved they they want to do a scam MH
so this chick I was
dating um she wanted to uh she wanted to
run a scam so I set up a scam it's semi
complicated but the the bottom line is
she ends up stealing a real person we we
we steal a real person's identity I have
a real person's identity we get a
driver's license in her name open up
some bank accounts go rent a piece of
property in her
name and I transfer the deed or the deed
from the property out of the real
owner's name I transfer it into her
stolen identity mhm we then refinance
the house like three or four times and
so she starts going to these different
closings and she's her name is Allison
and she's pretending to be a a a Puerto
Rican woman named Rosita
Perez
um Allison has brown hair and blue eyes
Rosita Perez clearly doesn't yeah so
Allison when when we make the ID she
dyes her hair
black curls it a little
bit um and gets the pictures pictures
taken of
herself but before she goes to the first
closing to get a check for like
$100,000 we've got like three of these
scheduled um
she she changes her hair color like that
she dyes it back like like a dirty
blonde and she goes to the first closing
and she gets a check a check for 100,000
let's say I don't know what it was like
either 95 or 105 whatever roughly
$100,000 she gets a check at the closing
they give it to her we then go to the
next closing well at the next
closing the the title
person has her sign all the documents
but she's looking at her like
something's not right looks at her ID
makes a copy of the ID looks at it and
says this this doesn't look like you and
she's like you know you don't look
Hispanic and she's like I'm half
Hispanic what do you what and she's like
you don't mean but keep in mind the
photograph was her so she's saying this
doesn't look like you but it's her
granted her she had you know the curly
hair a little bit but that's it so
Allison is like it's me and she she's
like look I'm not going to give cut you
I'm not going to give you the check yeah
I'm going to let you sign the documents
you know we can get you get the check I
I'll let you know so she goes gets in my
car she say yeah listen there's a
problem so we're driving down the road
she explains it to me I realize you know
okay that's done it's over we're not
going back she's like what about the
other closing no no no more closings
we're
done and and I you know and it was
probably more of a yell screaming and
yelling like what the hell did you do
why told you not to change your hair why
would you change your hair like that
when she came in like the day before and
I was like what did you do what did you
do and she's like I change my hair
what's the big deal it's still me sure
enough you know and that's
a like it's not that I knew that that
was going to happen but why tempt fate
how'd you meet Alison like she was a
mortgage broker okay and and I had done
some fraudulent she need she worked for
another mortgage company sorry I she
worked for another mortgage company she
couldn't get a loan closed the owner of
that mortgage company called me and said
look we got a loan we need it closed and
I said great and I used when guys would
call me I'd say great I'll come pick it
up I'll give you a $300 or $500 referral
fee no no it's a couple hundred, we want
to close it well if you then close it
well I can't close it we need a W2 or we
need this we need that we can't figure
out how to do it so I go over there and
typically I convince him just give it to
him it's not going to
close she was she was she was you'd have
to see this chick was gorgeous she was
gorgeous very flirtatious made me feel
like I was thin and handsome so
um like she gets whatever she wants um
so I'm like okay look here's what you do
and I explained to her do this do this
do this send it here it'll close and she
we close it well then she starts calling
me right hey how's it going we go to
lunch next thing you know we start
sleeping together she realizes what's
happening she says I want to I went in
on
this so now we do the
closings we're on our way I say look
that check's dead what she goes what
about the other the other one I go no no
it's all dead we're walking away now
that was easy for me to say because for
me I had money she's going through a
divorce she's broke you know like none
of this did I take into consideration at
the time by the way to me it's like n
that's dead we're done uh we we'll start
over again well and she's to her in her
mind she was about to make
we were getting probably that was a
million dollar scam she was about to end
up getting you know whatever it was half
or onethird of half a million dollars in
the next week now she's got nothing
so um she says look let's at least cash
this
one and I had a buddy named Travis
Hayes who had been you know we actually
were we've been friends since high
school we were like best friends right
really close friends in high school
we were still
close Travis was running a scan scam
this one hers was in Clearwater his was
in Orlando so I'm all I'm getting on all
over the state at this point right so
he's running an Orlando scam that's
already yielded half a million maybe
more he's still pulling we're still
refinancing properties right so he's
about to close on another half a million
dollars wor our properties he's got a a
bank account that's open she says let's
give it to Travis have him deposit it in
his account he's already pulled out like
300 000 out of the account and she's
like shouldn't be a problem I was like
um no no no and she goes let me call him
she calls
him I think I called him and and I
explained the situation he do you think
it's okay and I said no I don't think
it's okay I don't think it's okay at all
and he's like no it's not a big deal um
just give me the give me the check so I
give him the check he goes he deposits
the check they say they're going to hold
it till it clears you know that was kind
of a thing back then
um it takes I don't
know I don't know how long it took five
days six days whatever it was he was
supposed to go back and it would have
cleared and he would have been able to
start pulling money out and so I call
him one day because Allison's bugging me
so I call him and I go hey where you at
he goes I'm actually on my way to
Orlando and I said oh okay see but let
Allison know I'm not getting any money
he said the bank manager called and said
that because the check was over
$100,000 they have to witness me
endorsing the back of the check mhm or
they had to see my something right and
for me to come in I oh I said
something's wrong something's wrong
don't go to the bank um what do you
think's wrong I I think the cops are
waiting for you that's what I think's
wrong and he goes no the cops aren't he
go man I'm I'm in the parking lot right
now I just pulled in the parking lot
there's no cops I'm like they're not
going to be in squad cars like and he's
like no he said it's fine you're
overreacting bro and I'll never forget
what he said he said you're shaking like
a little girl bro calm down I got this
I'm cool with the manager like the man
manager like because you've chopped it
up with the manager he's going to let
your fraudulent check go through so he
walks
in the cops are in there they locked the
door he this told me later you know they
closed the door locked it the cops are
in there they grab
him and uh they bring him downtown he
didn't say anything he won't say
anything um that's not true by the way
um but he so here where he told me he
wouldn't say anything I told him I'm not
talking to you coppers oh he told yeah
told you but he actually did talk he
actually did talk to him so um he what
he ends up doing what ends up happening
is we can't get in touch with him yeah
so we're calling and calling and calling
and then finally I decide you know what
I'm not going to call his cell phone
anymore I'm going to
call the name of the person he was um
the the synthetic identities number
right so I go and I call the synthetic
identities number I call and I say
somebody answers it and I go hey is is
so and so there and he said and it's a
Gruff authoritarian voice you know it's
this is Law enfor and he's and he's like
no who's this he no he goes no this is
officer so- and so who's this and I go I
was like uh this is Lee black I said he
said he goes how do you know so and so I
was like oh no no click and I just hung
up and I called for like a pay phone so
I turned around I said he got arrested
and then later on that night he showed
up on the the county uh website you know
the the arrest website showing he had
been arrested
and uh the next day he calls me and he
asked me to get him out of jail like hey
I I you got to go so I I have to give
his brother-in-law money um you know we
get him out of jail he honestly got out
yeah he got out for like nothing and
here's what I should have known like he
was cooperating his it went from like
$300,000 Bond down to like $10,000 so
it's a, bucks so right then I didn't
know it at the time but obviously that
means we're going to let him out of jail
we he's cooperating
so they let him out of jail I go and I
get him a lawyer a state this was state
by the way it wasn't Federal so um I get
him a lawyer for like
$115,000 I he come you know he comes of
course he tells me look they ask me a
bunch of questions I told him that you
know I that he you know he made up some
story about there's he's working with
another guy but he doesn't know the
guy's name he made up a name like a
whole he has this whole kind of thing
where he tells him about me but not me
and like and the you know the numbers
none of the numbers LED anywhere so they
all Le lead to cell phones that are only
being used for those scams so it's a
dead alley or blind alley and uh I'm
like okay okay and I mean I'm paying him
like he's coming in man I my truck's no
good I need another truck I buy him
another truck hey man my the Electric's
going to get turned off and I don't have
oh I'm I need $1,000 of course here's
$1,000 I don't know what I was I'm
embarrassed you had to ask here's a
thousand you know week later you know he
needs 2,000 for this a th000 for this
2,000 for this he wants to start a tree
trimming company he needs to buy a tree
trimmer how much are those 5,000 of
course that's 10 so I give him another
25,000 starts like a tree trimming
business which he runs to this day
um what I don't know is that you know
the whole time he's actually working
with a a task force that's been put
together federal or this is State at
this point it's a state task force uh
because there's multiple is involved at
this point and it wasn't hard for him to
explain like this this is this comes
back to Reservoir Dogs I got a much all
he had to say to the officers was listen
you got to let me go I can't do any
prison time I'm going to tell you about
a much much bigger scam and they go okay
well how can you prove that scam pull up
Hillsboro County uh Hillsboro County's
tax appraiser website okay look up the
name James red look all of these were
buil bought 6 months ago 6 months later
they're all in foreclosure pull up Lee
black all of these were bought look 6
months later all of them are foreclosure
hey pull up James pull up Brandon green
pull up so all of these are going in
foreclose I it's it's so it's like you
know that what I thought was so cute not
cute it was just stupid and so he very
quickly they put together a task force
he's working with them on the task
force
and
um we're still buying houses flipping
houses doing everything cuz I'm I
believe him I believe he's not you know
he's saying look if I have to go to jail
for you know a year or so like you know
and he's also paying you know he hasn't
paid them back yet but he but we're
saying he can pay them back like it's
like look if we get to the point you
know when we get to that point like
we'll pay them
back um but we haven't paid them back
yet because we have no way to show where
that money came from we can always go to
like one of his relatives and give give
his dad 40 Grand give his mom 20 grand
you know that kind of stuff and start
putting money that way and all that that
money was taken out in cash too so we
could always show up with a chunk in
cash
regardless you know it's still in the
process and I think it we're still in
the process and and it could be six
months or a year away because it's a
slow thing I've already been through the
process my first time when I got in
trouble and it was a year but from the
time that I was spoken to until I pled
guilty and was
sentenced so um I'm not concerned about
it well that's happening we're still
flipping properties and one day
I have a buddy named Steve Sutton
remember the sheriff's deputy and keep
in mind it's funny because like I've
done bad loans for police officers
sheriffs um lawyers doctors like you
know across everybody across these
aren't like all you know yeah everybody
guys that you know these aren't all like
you know construction workers or guys
that work you know mechanics or
something these are like the legitimate
these are legitimate people that have
credit problems or whatever the the case
may be so one day I'm sitting at
work and
and I'd been getting phone calls for the
prior week from people at title
companies saying hey Matt wanted to let
you know we just had some subpoenas
served on several of your
files and I'm concerned like that had me
concerned then a guy named Jeff
testerman starts making phone calls Jeff
testerman is a reporter for the St
Petersburg Times he's
calling people saying hey um I know
noticed that you sold a piece of
property to Lee black have you ever met
Mr Black you asse like and they're like
just hanging up on him or saying no I
don't know what you're talking about I'm
not sure what that guy's name was let me
call you back and I'm getting phone
calls from people so I know something's
up with the newspaper now now I know
something's being looked at but nobody's
really talking I know that there are
subpoenas being um being served and I'm
I'm nervous you know I'm I'm very
concerned and then one day I'm in my
office and the sheriff's deputy walks in
Steve Sutton in his uniform too which
everybody always stiffened you know when
he would walk in so he walks in I go
Steve I said what's going on he's head
and usually he's jolly and laughs and
stuff and he goes and he says uh I got
to talk to you outside I was like okay I
walk outside what's up and he says uh
used to date this girl in the uh like
the Tampa Police Department or something
right I was like okay he say she showed
up at my house this morning at like 6
o'clock in the morning I went okay He
said she said that she's been working on
a task
force and he said Apparently one of your
buddies got arrested in Orlando uh
they're investigating some other thing
in Clearwater uh they're investigating a
ton of properties here in in ebore Tampa
Heights and I mean there's like a
hundred properties
involved and my name came up because
you've sold some properties to me which
I had and and he's like so she came to
me and said look your buddy Cox he said
and the I go I was like okay he goes he
said well the task force is on you and
she said to stop talking to you because
they're going to come arrest you in a
couple days they just handed over the
task force findings to the to the FBI
and the FBI is going to come arrest you
in a couple days and she said not to
talk to you because and because you're
you're going to
cooperate and because all white collar
guys cooperate so she thinks you're
going to cooperate and and not to talk
to you because she's afraid you're going
to get me hemmed up and she said just to
walk away and he was like so I thought
you should know and I was like okay and
he said uh what are you going to do I
said oh
um you know I I'm well first he said
what what should I do and I go tell them
tell them that I arranged all the loans
for you you came in you signed the
paperwork I filled out all the documents
you signed the paperwork you you know I
arranged everything I'm like you're not
a mortgage broker you don't know if this
is legit like you sign you have perfect
credit you signed the paperwork you
walked away with a check for 30,000 you
don't know yep and he was like cuz he
didn't cuz he had a job he was a
sheriff's deputy like I'm not a you know
I went in I applied I applied for a loan
at a bank they said we can buy you can
buy the house and we'll give you
$330,000 so of course I'm going to do
that you know that's not going to happen
but he doesn't know he's and and I said
tell him yeah tell him you'll cooperate
like
absolutely um he what are you going to
do I said me I said I'm I'm leaving bro
I'm leaving I said I can't I can't stay
here I can't go to prison like I was
just sentenced I'm on federal probation
right now like the judge isn't going to
be cool with me getting popped again
like I mean he I can't do it can't do it
I said I'm leaving can't go to prison
I'm adorable bro like you know I can't I
saw sha Shank Redemption I know what's
going to happen I can't yeah I can't do
that that's not going to happen like I I
can't you know I can't I'm not going to
defend myself against a guy who's 6'
three and tatted up no so and you know
and I can't I'm not I'm no benefit to a
gang yeah like I'm not I'm a nonviolent
you know soft white collar criminal so I
was just like uh I was like yeah I'm
leaving bro I'm leaving so I actually
went home well actually I was able to I
started cutting checks to people right
so I cut checks to uh Allison to Johnny
to like everybody I could think of
here's 5,000 here's 7,000 here's 8,000
here's six here's n and had them go into
all these different bank accounts
pulling out cash but this is like a
Thursday at 4 o'clock so the next day
they show up with cash write some more
checks they go again I get about 80
grand in cash that's all I can get um I
I I go home that night I start packing
my bags and I was dating this this chick
named uh Rebecca Hal we've been dating
about a month month
and she shows up at my house you know I
hadn't returned our phone calls all day
and apparently we were supposed to go
out and I'd forgotten about it I had
bigger issues and so I'm packing a
couple of duffel bags and she walks in
and she's like what's going on I'm like
um I'm leaving where you going I thought
we were supposed to go out at such and
go do something tonight I'm like I'm
leaving it's over and and she says what
happened I tell her what happened this
is what happened she's like oh my God
like she had no idea she had no idea
about anything you were doing no I
barely knew her like I mean she's coming
over two three times a week for a month
like I've you know this isn't love this
isn't you know this is a booty call
that's all it is like we're hanging out
we're having sex and that's it I don't
even know you
so she suddenly just begs to come with
me you got to bring me with you you have
to this you have that I'm like what are
you talking about like you you've got a
uh you've got a son you have your mom
lives here you're and she's just in
tears and crying and she suddenly said
this is what's so funny about is that
she had just moved
from Vegas to to um St Petersburg to
work at the dog track to work for a
company that owned the dog track right
the a casino interest or yeah like a
gambling company and uh she said you
don't even know why I'm here I was like
okay why are you here she said I'm here
because I was working for a law firm
that worked for the the um Casino
company that I work for she
said I got caught embezzling nothing it
was like 10 or $15,000 from my
boss cuz she had a gambling habit and
she said he didn't call the police
because we were sleeping together and he
was afraid his wife would find out she
said so instead he banished me here to
St
Pete my son just came to live with me
he's been caught sneaking out uh because
he her the father had raised him he'd
only been living with her since she got
to Florida and she's like I was about I
was going to send him back he's failing
school he's smoking pot he's been caught
sneaking out after curfew I'm like oh
okay I I don't know any of this she's
like he was going back in December you
well no he was going back after the
school year which would have been like
May okay and I'm like so where before
five minutes earlier I thought she was
this sweet secretary sweet innocent
secretary and and she's like you know
I've been married three times I'm a
gambler I've BL bankruptcy I'm sleeping
with my old boss I got like you know she
went from this you know thieving
adulteress you know and I thought these
are all really beneficial to my you know
my future plans yeah you know and I
shouldn't have at that moment you know I
was so just flipped out and concerned
and up and leaving your life and
everything you know
behind that's a that's terrifying and
you know and and so now you're alone in
a strange place in a place is the first
time you've done something like that
like leave to go on the road yes so I
never just up and moved and and keep in
mind now I can't call home I can't like
I'm I'm leaving there there are things
that I feel like get you caught mhm and
every you know I've watched tons of
these TV shows and you know there are
certain things that get you caught you
know one of them is keeping in contact
with anybody in your old life so I'm
thinking that's that's not going to
happen like I'm not I'm not contacting
anybody I'm leaving and that's it that
didn't really happen I kept in touch I
call my mom every once in a while but I
was
like um okay that's cool did the
loneliness of that hit you early on or
no like as you packing I never did well
you're leaving your life I mean there's
a it feels like a fundamental transition
oh listen you think I mean listen not
just that like I'm leaving my my son I
have a son and I'm you know I was I was
leaving everything I was just terrified
of going going to prison and you know I
mean I don't it was just it was just so
stupid it was just arrogance and you
know I should have stayed like I made
things so much worse but I I also
thought I'm
smart I can I can figure this out like I
can change my identity blend in I'll be
fine aren't you already like people know
what your face looks like they do they
do but I one of the first things I did
was I got plastic surgery what what kind
of plastic I've got I've got a nose job
I got uh what they call a mini face lift
they go in through your back of your
ears and they suck out all the fat in
your neck does that change appearance
much uh a little bit um I got I was
balding
I got two hair transplants you know two
hair graphs so the hair in my head this
is my hair it's my hair but it's from
back here so there's they cut it from
here I appreciate it um so they
reimplanted it there uh you know got
lipos suction and just some you know
other stuff and you know got my teeth
done that sort of thing you know
so you know and I that's was kind of
like my plan I'll go I'll take off I got
80 grand I'll steal some more money you
know but I I let her come with me
and we ran up all my credit cards over
the next few days packed up the car
traded in my my Audi and got like an
Audi I don't know was it like an A6 or
like a four-door like the big four-door
whatever it was um got that and uh drove
straight to
Atlanta and
um so I I wrote a letter to my parents
before I left just explaining this is
what's happening I'm leaving I'm done
I'm not going to prison
love you sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry I
know I'm a disappointment sorry
bam